comedian Tom Segura is a busy guy with
television credits that include Conan
Comedy Central and live at Gotham he
doesn't stop there
yeah he spends a lot of time on stage
and this weekend he's going to be at the
funny bone here at destiny USA so we
welcome them in this one good morning so
man shut up to Mercer shout out to the
Bristol stool chart I had number 5 that
soft blobs with clear cut edges because
I need fiber there you go now I got to
ask about the get up here you were
expecting a blizzard in Syracuse
obviously now it's just how I roll my
number like this in July I don't care if
it's humid I don't care if it's a
hundred and five
I wear fur because there's an old saying
happy hoes eat sad hoes don't and I try
to stay happy words to live by
Gary Goggins yes to live by um so you
were tweeting and instagramming before
the show yeah you know hashtag DJ dad
mouth so what's up that is that what we
should call you I mean I appreciate it
I'm gonna be doing stand-up but my focus
is on the after party always so I'll be
tweeting out a location for a surprise
Oh pop-up show and you too that's are
both invited oh that's like a bonus
freebie Friday yeah that is right yeah a
party like that so um so what DJ dad
mouth I have a question for you yeah
random question okay why is Bert
Chrysler so fat that's a good question
merchant alcoholic and he's not he's
diabetic
and he's on a lot of medication and he's
just a sad he's a sad hope like we were
just talking about sad hose I supposed
to not eat but he's so sad he eats extra
and that's why birds so fat yeah I had I
had to ask
curiosity got the best of me no really
that's what happens that's what happens
um you are married to a comedian right
yeah so she's a woman so is it is it
like just totally hilarious at home or
is it like really low-key what's it like
at home it's a it's not a lot of laughs
man
a lot of smells a lot of smells there's
a smelly house we have a baby kids baby
that's one kid kid but sometimes at all
you need that's all it takes
yeah I mean look there's a lot of action
in the home too you know like I got I
got kids that she doesn't know about so
sometimes when she's out of the house
I'll bring other kids over that are
older than our baby they kind of play in
the house then they leave and then you
know you know how go I do know how it
goes and speaking of house let's talk
about your mom's house yeah your mom's
house that's a lot of fun it's the best
man your mom's house podcast it's where
you know it's kind of like it's I feel
like it's a Bible for a lot of people
you know yeah um there's we cover up the
important issues you know like like what
farts um we we cover love how you say
that with just such a straight face sup
Mercer all kinds of stuff man
we cover what was the thing this week
man I I never had a job in my life so I
started doing this you know I've been in
out of jail you know saying I did a
little bit of everything but now I'm
like now you walk around with her you
know saying yeah Angela he's reached the
pinnacle good boy yeah heckle right now
you're right there I'm right there man
my sensei Segal uh I was telling me
about that the Buddha nature is just to
be in the moment so that's what I'm
trying to do right now I think you're
doing it really well actually
and speaking of being in the moment if
you want to join Tom and be in the
moment you can do so tonight live at the
funny bone at 7:30 and 9:45 he's got two
shows as well as tomorrow night 7:30
9:45 special engagement for tickets give
them a call for two three eight six six
nine or visit them online Syracuse at
funny man Saturday 7:30 shows almost
sold out yes oh you got your tickets
I've got 11 kids man oh my gosh how do
you do it I got you a name a rescue man
no don't don't
okay yeah I don't want to know I don't
want to know I don't want oh my goodness
you opened their safe be a nurse ha ha
ha
why